okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of
science and technology q a for kids
and others so i think we have a few
questions left over from last time
i see one here from omarita the question
was do protons decay
okay interesting question we don't know
the answer for sure yet
uh nobody has yet seen a proton decay
what would it mean first of all what
does it mean
for a proton to decay it means that
if you had a proton
that it would simply spontaneously turn
into a collection of other particles
so say does that happen for any of the
particles we ordinarily know well it
does happen for neutrons
so atomic nuclei consists of
clumps of protons and neutrons all stuck
together by the strong nuclear force
and so for example helium for instance
the most common version of helium
has two protons and two neutrons in its
nucleus that's helium-4
the four means a total of four protons
and neutrons
so helium-4 is stable
the two neutrons that are in the nucleus
of helium-4
are perfectly stable as are the protons
but if you were to separate a neutron
out and you had a free neutron it turns
out the free neutrons left on their own
not
bound into atomic nuclei actually decay
in about 15 minutes
so what happens in in the neutron
decays into a proton an electron
and in fact an anti-neutrino so
you to figure out what something can
decay into
you have to work out uh what what
things it has to conserve and what
things it does not conserve so in the
case of uh
one of the things that seems to be a
thing that gets conserved in the
universe is
electric charge so you can't create or
destroy electric charge
so a neutron is electrically neutral
and so if it's going to decay into
something it has to decay into
things where the the total of what it
decays into is also electrically
neutral neutral so protons have an
electric charge of plus one unit
electrons have an electric charge of
minus one units neutrinos have no
electric charge
so a neutron to say it decays into a
proton
an electron and an anti-neutrino that
works
in terms of of conserving electric
charge because the protons plus one
minus the electron is minus one the
neutrino doesn't contribute anything
the next big question is does
is there uh can it
when it decays it will have a certain
mass
and if it's going to decay into other
things the
total mass of the things it decays into
must be less than the mass it has itself
because otherwise it it doesn't it's not
possible for it to just sort of create
mass from nothing so when a neutron
decays into a proton electron
anti-neutrino
it so happens that the mass of a neutron
it's just a little bit higher
than the mass of a proton um plus the
mass of an electron so
neutron mass is a little bit higher than
the sum of the mass is a proton electron
and the antineutrino has almost zero
mass
um so it's because the mass
of the neutron is a little bit higher
than that some of those masses that it
can decay into a proton
electron and neutrino now it turns out
when a neutron is inside a nucleus like
helium-4
it has it is bound inside the nucleus
strongly enough
that effectively its mass is reduced by
enough
that prevent the possibility of it
decaying in the way that i just
described
so a few free neutron if which isn't
bound inside a nucleus can decay in 15
minutes
or so but bound inside a nucleus
it usually doesn't brown inside where
it's tightly bound inside a nucleus like
it is in the case of
of of helium-4 it can't decay
okay so what about protons
if a proton was to decay what would it
decay into
well has to conserve charge so
that means it should be decaying into a
positively charged particle what
positively charged particle
is lighter than a proton so the only
answer that we know of to that
is a positron the antiparticle of the
electron
so a proton weighs in the units usually
used in these
kinds of things about 938
mev mev stands for mega electron volts
that's just a unit of of um of mass in
in
um uh in kilograms it will be
i think 10 to the minus 26 kilograms or
so
but it's more convenient to talk about
in terms of mev the um
uh the proton weighs about 938 mev
the um uh the electron is about 1800
times
lighter than a proton electrons only
weigh about 0.51
mev and so that and positrons
uh have the same mass as electrons
that's a rule for antiparticles of
always have the same mass they have the
opposite charge
but they have the same mass so a
positron has charge plus one
mass 0.5 mev and so
in terms of just pure energy in terms of
just pure mass
a proton could decay into a positron
plus
maybe a bunch of neutrinos okay the
question is does it
and uh what happened in the around the
late 1970s
people developed a bunch of theories
so-called grand unified theories
which said it should be the case that
protons can decay
in the way that i just said into
positrons and so on
um and so people went and looked for
decays of protons and they didn't find
them
so let me describe both why people
thought the protons should decay
how they looked for proton decay and
what we know about that so far
so in terms of why protons uh
should decay okay
here's the basic idea so it all has to
do with these things called gauge
theories
and um the uh uh
in in studying things like
protons and neutrons and quarks and
photons and electrons and all these
kinds of particles
that exist it's um uh the
the sort of the the main way to study
those is using
uh quantum field theory and in
particular using
this idea of gauge fields let's see if i
can explain how gage fields work
so essentially the notion is
that this is a little going to be a
little tricky let's see what i can do
here
um the simplest example of a gauge field
is electromagnetism the fact that
photons exist
can be seen as a consequence of
this notion of local gauge invariance
all right let me see if i can explain
how this works
so let's say you have an electron
an electron is has an electric charge
electric charge produces an electric
field
it uh when there's an electric charge
electric charges
two unlike charges will attract like
charges will repel the way we
represent that phenomenon is through the
presence of this electric field we
imagine that there's this
there's this uh uh there's this
there's this field that exists that is
generated by the electron
but exists outside of the electron
exists everywhere if another electron
is also uh in this field
there will be a force on that other
electron as a result of the field
and the way it works is the field of a
single
point charge is this thing that looks
like a sort of idealized hedgehog it has
all of these kinds of lines of electric
field
that go out uh in in all directions from
that electric charge
okay so now so that means you've got
this this charge it's got this electric
field the electric field goes out in all
directions
if you try to say well where is their
electric charge okay we can we can see
where it is because we can go in any
direction we can go as far away as we
want
and we can see can we can we detect an
electric field
that was a consequence of this kind of
hedgehog electric field lines that came
out of this charge
the the intensity of the electric field
goes down like
well like an inverse square like one
over the distance squared
but nevertheless there's there's some uh
electric field even as far as far away
as you as you might go
okay so now let's imagine that we move
that electric charge
the one that we have just at the origin
we move it we just
push it a bit okay so eventually
it better be the case so so when we move
it it's going to move to a new position
and it's got a new set of electric field
lines coming out of it
so we go far away from these this
electric charge
the electric field lines have to have
shifted because they're now the electric
field lines from a from a different
position of electric charge
the question is how does that process
work how do the field lines sort of
realign themselves for the new position
of the electric charge
and the answer is you have to have some
kind of there has to be some
front that you know you've got this one
kind of hedgehog like like shape
you're going to get to another one there
has to be some sort of front that exists
and the first one
that kind of goes outwards kind of
sharing the information that yes the
electric charge in the middle moved
so that front the existence of that
front is electromagnetic radiation
that's that is the thing that kind of
establishes that something like a photon
must exist
the fact that you somehow have to convey
the information
that this that you move the charge
around
it has to be conveyed that information
has to eventually be conveyed as far
away as
as as you choose to look and that
information
gets conveyed as it turns out at the
speed of light uh
and it gets conveyed by the presence of
essentially photons
that sort of carry the information that
the electric charge moved
so in a sense whenever there's something
like an electric charge
that has that generates this field and
by the by by the way that you have
convey information about a change of
that
of the electric charge is by the
presence
of particles like photons so it's sort
of an inevitable feature once there's
this electric field and
it works the way that it works it's
inevitable that there must be things
like photons that exist
that sort of carry information about
that field around
okay so the thing that
um uh
what's what's a little complicated is
that
when um
how to explain this i'll tell you the
the fancy words that describe it
um there's this notion
uh it's the theory of of gage groups
and things called lee groups um spelled
l-i-e
uh and um it has to do with
okay so when we have ordinary electric
charge
it's just a number it's just you know
something has charge plus one
plus two uh charge whatever it's just
some
it's just a number there are different
kinds of charges
that work in a more complicated way so
for example
quarks have a thing called color charge
and the analog of photons for quarks is
gluons
gluons are the particles that kind of
carry the information about color about
the color field
um and uh unlike uh photons
okay so so what happens with the with
color charge is more complicated than
happens
with ordinary electric charge with color
charge
there isn't just one number that
characterizes the color charge of a cork
color charge kind of comes in three
directions it's kind of like red green
blue colors
and a quark can have
uh you you can you can
kind of uh uh there's a when a sort of a
red quark
emits a uh a green anti-red gluon for
emits a red anti-green glue on and then
maybe it turns into a green quark
in other words unlike in the case where
there aren't real colors this is just
mathematically
talked about in terms of colors but um
uh when an electron
emits a photon it does not change
its charge when a quark emits a gluon
it does change its color charge and uh
it does it in this kind of the kind
these three directions of color charge
um
that that exists and
one of the many complexities is that
whereas a photon does not have electric
charge
a gluon does have color charge so
photons don't directly interact with
each other because they don't they're
not
attracted by electric charge to each
other because they don't have electric
charge themselves gluons on the other
hand
are do have color charge so they have
interactions between themselves
and that creates a lot of complexity in
understanding how quarks and gluons work
and is is the reason
that you can't separate two quarks apart
i mean when you
if you start pulling quarks apart apart
there will be gluons that will generate
a um essentially a a
color field between the quarks but
because these glue ones interact with
each other
instead of the the sort of the field
lines going out like a hedgehog
all in different directions all
independent these gluons interact with
each other and they pull
essentially the field lines together so
instead of instead of these quarks just
having
uh like sort of the the fields going out
in all directions and having sort of an
inverse square law
of what the intent what the density of
these sort of hedgehog lines is
um as uh as as you go out to a certain
distance
instead of all of that these gluons
interact with each other and they pull
the field lines together
so what happens is that instead of these
field lines going out in all directions
they're pulled together into this kind
of string
between the two quarks so instead of it
being the case that as you pull these
quarks apart
they are sort of more and more uh less
and less affected
by by the force by color forces
associated with the other quark
they're affected just as much as you
pull them but in fact even more so
as you pull them further and further
apart because you get all of this
all of what was uh all of this kind of
color
field is concentrated in this sort of
string between these two corks
it's not the way that if you've heard of
string theory it's not the way that
modern string theory works it's the way
that a
previous iteration of that kind of
string theory talked about those kinds
of things
but um the uh in any case
so so that's a case so quarks are a case
where
um the there is the same kind of idea of
something like electric charge
electric fields electromagnetic fields
photons and so on but it works a little
differently
the official name is it's a so-called
non-abelian gauge field
that means that it's a gauge field that
interacts with itself as well as
interacting with
the source of field like the quarks and
so on okay
long story here but but basically what
was found was
that in particle physics
there are um you can characterize these
different kinds of charges and there are
three different kinds of charges
that show up in particle physics color
charges from quarks
uh electric charges from
electromagnetism and a third kind of
charge that's associated with the
so-called weak interaction
um that uh is the thing that leads to uh
certain kinds of radioactive decay beta
decay and so on
um it's again a little bit complicated
because there's a mixing
between the the electromagnetic force
and this weak
charge piece but but roughly there these
three separate things
color weak force electromagnetism and
they're all characterized by
these they can be written down
mathematically
in terms of uh basically saying
in terms of these these groups that
define
um um that they're they're basically
describing
sort of how many directions of how many
uh how many
numbers in effect characterize each kind
of charge roughly
and so the official version
of the standard model of particle
physics it's a su-3
cross su-2 cross u1
and the su-3 the the three is the sort
of three directions of color charge the
su-2
has to do with weak charges and the u1
has to do with electromagnetism
and just the scalar this number that
characterizes electric
electric charge roughly that's how it
works i could go into
a great deal more detail here um it's uh
uh but that's a that's a um a rough
picture of how that works
okay so people wondered uh
how come the these different things the
strong interactions the the
gluon stuff the uh the weak stuff
and the ultramarine stuff how come
they're all separate surely there must
be some unification of these things
surely there must be some way
to have sort of a a a a
a sort of global kind of charge that
just as special cases has color charge
weak charge electromagnetic charge
and so what people imagined is that
all these things might be combined into
let's say a five direction thing
s su-5 or something
that that just only special cases of
which correspond to strong interactions
weak interactions of magnetism
so there was this kind of idea there
would be this sort of master version
of things that would be uh would include
all of those
okay so one consequence of having that
master version
is it means that there have to be
uh processes that will turn
things that are usually associated with
uh
the um the strong forces
the the the qcd forces the gluon forces
into things that are usually associated
with these weak forces so in the
language of
particle physics these things that are
subject to that are made of quarks and
gluons and so on
are called hadrons um things that
interact
strongly with each other things that are
subject only to the weak forces or
social electromagnetism
are called leptons um there that that
word comes from the greek leptos which
means light um because
those were these used to be the
particles that had lower mass although
now there are heavier leptons that have
been found so that's a little bit
confusing
but um uh one of the features of of kind
of unifying together
all these different things is it implies
that the quark-like things
must be able to be transformed into
the the electron-lepton-like things
by emitting some kind of particle and
that particle
would actually be a particle that in
effect lives on a very very short time
um but it's a it's nevertheless and it's
a it's something which
would be happen that process would
happen potentially only very very very
rarely
and so people tried to work out well how
often would it happen
and one idea was maybe it happens maybe
the
average lifetime of a proton might be 10
to the 30th years
so that means that's 10 to the 30th
means
a trillion trillion billion if i got my
math roughly right
years so that's a long time i mean our
universe is only 15 billion years old
but the way these things work when you
say that something has a lifetime of
such and such a number of years
what that actually means that the most
common thing to quote is the so-called
half-life
and what that means is after you say it
has a half-life of a year
okay that means when one year has gone
by
half the examples of that thing will
have decayed
when two years have gone by half squared
examples will have decayed
and so on and um so
it'll be um and so the the um
this idea so what happens is every every
time
there's a uh it halves every time
you go another half-life of time forward
so
the first year it's halved in the second
year it'll halve again
third year will have again and so on so
that's that's the notion of a half-life
and from what we know about quantum
mechanics
and the way microscopic particles work
um things that just freely decay into
other things
will always decay on this you know you
halve the amount of
uh you half more of the things will
decay
during the next period of a half of of
that half-life
and so the calculation was that the
half-life of the proton
might be around 10 to the 30th years so
you'd say how could you possibly detect
something which decays only only that
slowly well the answer is
if you have enough protons then the
chances are
that one of them even if the half-life
is 10 to the 30th
that means even in one year some tiny
fraction of those protons will decay
it's just it would take you 10 to the
30th years for half the protons in a
sample
to decay and so what people did was they
were interested in looking for
if you have a giant tank of water for
example could there be
just one proton in a year that
in this giant tank of water that might
contain oh you know 10 to the 30th
protons for example
might there be one proton in that tank
that
that decays in in the whole year what
would it look like if the proton decay
well the proton
is going to turn into a let's say a
positron and some neutrinos
and um it's uh so what does that what
does that actually mean well it means
there's a proton it's sitting there it's
sitting in a tank of water
it's maybe it's been one of the
hydrogens of the of the water that
um that you have there and suddenly
it decays and what will happen when it
decays is
all the energy associated with the mass
of that proton will be turned into
kinetic energy will be turned into the
motion of the electron
so there'll be this this proton will
just be sitting there and then this
electron will whiz out of the
out of where the proton was and to to
conserve momentum
there'll be some neutrinos that go in
the opposite direction but neutrinos
don't interact much so you probably
won't see them
but they'll be basically what will
happen is you'll go from this thing
where there was just
a quiescent you know just a bunch of
water there and then suddenly
this this um uh positron
that has a whole bunch of energy that's
taking probably let's say half the
energy of the
of the of the mass of the proton it's
going to suddenly start zooming through
the water
okay so how would you detect that you've
got this giant tank of water
how would you detect that just one uh
you know proton
decayed and produce this high-energy
positron
well boy i'm having to explain a whole
bunch of physics here
okay so there is a phenomenon called
cherenkov radiation
this is one of the one of the ways you
there are variety of ways you could
detect
that electron but one way that's pretty
good way to detect that
like that positron um is with this thing
called triangle radiation i'll
let me talk about that in a moment um so
but in any case what what people tried
to do back around 1980 or so
was they tried to get giant tanks of
things like water
and they tried to see you just set it
somewhere and you tried to see is there
suddenly
this sort of flash of of a decay of a
proton
okay now one of the problems is
uh you just put a tank of water out
there in your backyard or whatever
all kinds of weird things will happen to
it for example
one of the things that will happen is
there are cosmic rays that come mostly
from the sun
just as we get light from the sun
there's also a stream of protons that
come from the sun
and those protons hit the upper
atmosphere of the earth
and uh they usually interact there and
eventually they produce muons
near the surface and they produce some
electrons and other things
but um actually i just got a little
detector which is now connected to my
computer and i have to
have to have a look at it again but but
which actually detects cosmic rays
um as they go through my computer but
every you know
if you have a if you have for us the
size we are so to speak
oh roughly every minute or so at sea
level at least
there will be a cosmic ray particle that
goes through us
so if you have your giant tank of water
and it's out in your backyard
every so often there'll be a cosmic ray
particle that comes from the sun
typically that goes through it and that
can produce
the same kind of effects as one of these
proton decays so that's a bad thing
because you might say
i got a proton decay but you'd be wrong
because it would actually be just this
cosmic ray particle from the sun
so how do you avoid that well the answer
is you put your tank of water
really deep down so there's a giant
bunch of rock
between where the cosmic rays are coming
and where your tank of water is so
people found
all these places like deep mines that
are several miles below the ground where
people have
have dug down to uh to mine for gold or
mine for other kinds of
of of uh materials and so
these giant tanks of water were put in
deep mines another another place where
there was
some i think a proton decay experiment
was done was in the road tunnel
in the mont blanc in the alps in the uh
mont blanc the tallest mountain in the
alps there's a tunnel
a road tunnel uh through it and by the
time you got that great big mountain on
top of you
that's a pretty big pile of rock that um
can
shield out the cosmic rays but anyway so
people look for proton decay
and they didn't find it and um so so far
as we know
protons are stable at least we know that
their lifetime is i think probably more
than about 10 to the 32 years
um so protons aren't sort of readily
decaying
now i'm going to give two little side
side shows to this
there is some reason to believe that at
some point
protons must decay um because
there are a bunch of explanations in
fact i was involved in some of these
um for why there is more matter than
antimatter in the universe
that rely on the fact that eventually it
must be possible for protons to decay
that's a slightly complicated story to
tell maybe i'll tell a lot of people are
interested
uh i just to come back on one other
thing i was talking about was tranquil
radiation let me explain that it's kind
of interesting
so uh
if you so
if you're a plane flying through the air
and
you hear the plane it's got its engines
it's got
a lot of a lot of turbulence in the
airflow around the plane
you're on the ground you hear the plane
okay the speed of sound
the speed at which the sound from the
plane gets to you is faster than
your typical average you know passenger
plane or something flies at
okay so here's a weird thing that can
happen let's say the plane is flying
faster than the speed of sound the
question is what happens
to the sound of the plane as it flies
through the air
and the answer is that the
all that sound is kind of concentrated
in the sonic boom
which is this kind of cone of effect
that the plane has on the air that it's
going through
and it's a general thing you know if you
if you ride a bicycle through a puddle
you'll see that there's a um uh you are
you're you can if you're riding at a
reasonable speed you're riding
faster than the speed of waves
on the surface of the water and so
you'll see this kind of wake
that comes back in a kind of um in a
triangle
uh behind behind where you are those
that that that kind of that idea of of
uh
what what's happening is whenever you
are going
faster than the speed
of whatever let's say it's sound
or water waves on the surface of the
water when you're
uh when you have a thing that's going
faster than the local speed
of that um
uh of of of sort of transmitting
information you get this kind of um
uh you get this kind of shock wave you
get this thing that in the case of sound
is a sonic boom
in the case of um of water waves it's
kind of this
this um this sort of uh dramatic wake
okay so uh this also happens with light
so the fastest light ordinarily goes at
the speed of light
but the speed of light is a certain
speed
in the vacuum if there's nothing if the
light is not interacting with anything
but as soon as the light is in a uh is
going through something like water for
example it goes slower than it does in
the vacuum what's happening is
the photons are coming into the water
the photons keep on getting absorbed by
an atom and then re-emitted by the atom
but there's a slight delay for the
re-emission
so in water the speed of light is about
1.3 times slower than it is in the
vacuum so
the um uh okay so that's just a fact
well turns out in the case of something
like proton decay
that positron will have been pushed out
and it will be going faster
than the uh
than the speed of light in the water so
faster than the 1.3 times slower than
the
uh than the speed of light in a vacuum
so it'll be going close to the speed of
light in a vacuum
which is faster than the speed of light
in water
and so what happens is that you get the
analog of a sonic boom
but now with light instead of with sound
you get this cone of light produced
that is the result of the um actually i
should if the
if the positron is going that way the
cone is becomes behind the positron
um the cone of light produced by the um
uh by this particle that's going through
the water faster than
the speed of speed of light in water and
so this
this produces tranquil light is usually
uh it's bluish light
um if you're because of the way the
spectrum of the light works
it'll appear to be blue light and so
what happens is when this positron is
produced there's a little flash of blue
light
that is the trench radiation associated
with
uh that thing going through the water
and so
people trying to detect proton decay one
of the methods was you just put a lot of
uh
essentially cameras officially photo
multiplier tubes but they're basically
cameras
on all sides of this water and it's
completely black and then suddenly
there's a little flash of light and that
flash of light is the trench of
radiation
from one of these high energy particles
going through the water
now so people looked for did they have
these flashes of light from proton decay
and numbers that were found so anyway
that's the
that's the long story of of uh proton
decay maybe i should say something about
why
we think protons might decay
boy i'm i'm i thought this was going to
be an easy one to answer
this this is this is what's always
interesting about this for me is that
there's a certain sort of map of what
there is to know in an area like physics
and there's like to talk about one thing
how much other stuff do you have to talk
about
to be able to explain that one thing all
right let me let me talk about another
sort of interesting piece of sort of
physics meets
the the universe as we live in it um
the uh um uh the question
the question is there's mata like
protons and electrons and so on i think
in previous live streams i've talked
about antimatter
which has positrons which are
anti-electrons antiprotons
all these things are the are the
negative charge version the the opposite
charge version
of ordinary particles you combine them
together
they will just turn into things like
photons and so on
that they'll essentially just turn into
energy
um okay so one of the things that's
really weird
is that in our universe that
we didn't end up with an equal amount of
matter and antimatter
when i was a kid it still seemed
possible
that other galaxies might be made of
antimatter
that our galaxy is made of matter but
maybe the andromeda galaxy the nearest
other spiral galaxy big galaxy might be
made of antimatter
that seemed like a possible hypothesis
and maybe what would happen is that
half the galaxies in the universe might
be made of antimatter and half might be
made of matter
and one might even imagine all kinds of
weird and crazy things like
some galaxies rotate clockwise others
rotate anti-clockwise maybe the
anti-galaxies are rotating
anti-clockwise who knows all kinds of
weird things might be true
but it turns out there's pretty good
evidence that that's not the way things
work there's pretty good evidence that
every galaxy in the universe
is a galaxy not an anti-galaxy that
there's basically matter in the universe
but not
any significant amount of antimatter and
so it was hard to understand how that
would be the case because a lot of
theories about how the universe started
will have meant that there will be an
equal amount of matter and antimatter
produced
and you have to kind of explain why why
it didn't stay that way
and the main way of explaining that has
to do with the fact that the antimatter
in some sense
decays away and the way that that decay
process
works has to be the same kinds of
processes as what caused proton decay in
the current
universe so in in that explanation of
why there's more matter than antimatter
it has to be the case that there is some
process by which protons to decay
and that process will have happened very
very quickly at the beginning of the
universe
now will be a really slow process to do
with protons just really slowly again
but we haven't seen this and so we don't
really know that that's correct but
that's the
that's the current theory for for why
they're sort of not more matter than
antimatter and i'm not going into the
technical details of how that works
so happened i was involved in working
out that theory back around 1980s so
if my memory is still working i could
probably tell you in great detail how
the theory works
um it actually involves some fairly
elaborate physics
that sort of a mixture of the physics of
large-scale
cosmology and large-scale features of
gravity
together with the physics of
statistical mechanics of of things where
there are a large number of elements
large number of
particles in a system and how that works
together with particle physics together
with one field theory
it's actually a fairly complicated um uh
collection of different areas of
physics that have to come together to
explain these this why there's more
matter than antimatter
um in the universe um but maybe for
another time
all right let's go down some more of
these
okay there's a question from ollie here
theoretically if there was a ladder
stretching from earth to a distant
planet say a light year away
could you communicate with folks there
instantly by pushing and pulling the
ladder say in morse code style
uh interesting question okay
so the basic problem is if
that let's say you have this ladder so
you have this pole
and it was a whole light year long or
four light years long so it was
reached all the way from here to the
nearest star alpha nearest star than the
sun alpha centauri
okay you say that's a very very long
pole
but now let's say we push on the end of
the pole so our usual experiences
if we have a solid object we push one
end of the solid object
and the other end of the solid object
will move instantaneously it's like we
just have this pole
so great we just push it and the other
end will move
okay well it doesn't really quite work
that way
what's happening is that pole is
ultimately made of atoms and the atoms
have forces that keep them set up in
this kind of solid
structure that they're set up in but
when we push
one end what's happening is we're
pushing the atoms at one end
they have to push the next set of atoms
they push the next set of atoms they
push the next set of atoms
and actually it isn't the case that that
the
the pushing that we do here immediately
gets to the other end
instead what's happening is that we are
compressing
this end of our pole and we have this
little region of compression
and the atoms at this end they're
pushing on the next set of atoms they're
pushing on the next set of atoms
and they're pushing this region of
compression down the pole
so actually we already know of something
similar that happens
when we're talking in the air
what we're doing is the our vocal tract
is moving and that's pushing the air
and we push the air and as we push the
air
we are producing waves of compression
in the air and those waves of
compression move at the speed of sound
in air
um about 600 miles an hour um
they'll they'll move but it doesn't
happen instantaneously the
the the molecules of air that we pushed
on with our throat so to speak
get they will push on other molecules
they will push on other molecules
and that process of moving that
information
from one set of molecules to the next
occurs at the speed of sound which is
about 600 miles an hour 700 miles an
hour
um the uh 330 meters per second
is a more accurate uh value for the
speed of sound at standard temperature
and pressure
um it depends on the pressure of the air
and so on
okay so that's what happens in a gas and
air if you have a solid object piece of
steel or something
and you push on one end of that piece of
steel exact same thing happens
you produce a region of compression and
that region of compression
gradually moves down the steel the the
steel pole
at a certain speed it moves down that
steel pole actually at the speed of
sound in steel
so because sound normally it's it's
carried by the
air but you can also conduct sound
through something like steel you're
compressing one end of the steel
and you're getting the um uh the the the
that compression
is gradually moving down the piece of
steel so for example
uh when you um if you're
i don't know if you if you have a um
let's say you have a metal pipe and you
bang on one piece of the metal pipe
and somebody hears you a different piece
of the metal pipe that's
sound that is being uh conducted through
the metal pipe
not through the air okay so the question
is how fast does sound go in a metal
pipe
or how fast does sound go in a piece of
steel as opposed to
um in the air and i'm not remembering
precisely but it goes at a
few thousand miles an hour um and i
don't remember exactly how many
and it depends on some details of the
material but
just as in in air sound goes at maybe
650 miles an hour
in something like a steel bar let's say
it goes at 2500 miles an hour i'm not
sure if that's exactly right and it will
depend on details
but so it's still the case that just
like sound travels at a certain speed
the effect of this compression will
travel a certain speed in this material
so let's say we have the steel pole and
it's four light years long
and it's going all the way to alpha
centauri and we
tap on one end of it push one end of it
the problem is
that the thing isn't completely rigid
it'll be it'll have this
this wave of compression that goes and
it keeps going and it keeps going and if
we
if if it'll probably actually in
practice die out but assuming it didn't
die out
it would keep going keep going keep
going eventually we'll get to alpha
centauri
but it would take a really long time so
if if we sent
a photon of light then it would go at
the speed of light
if we send this essentially sound wave
in our in our pole
it will go at the speed of sound in that
pole and the question of how big is that
speed of sound
compared to the speed of light well the
speed of sound is always less than the
speed of light in any material that we
know
right now as the material gets more
rigid
the speed of light gets closer to the
speed of sound gets closer to the speed
of light
so in air which is not rigid at all the
speed of sound is comparatively slow
as we go to more and more rigid
materials stronger and stronger metals
and things like that
the speed of sound will go up to
thousands you know 5 000 miles an hour
that type of thing still
tiny compared to the speed of light but
if we imagine a
uh a material which we certainly can't
make
that would be incredibly incredibly
rigid
eventually we will get up to speeds that
are close to the speed of light
uh in terms of how fast sound can
propagate but never as fast as the speed
of light so
you'll never win relative to relative to
just sending a photon or sending a radio
signal
you'll never be able to get something to
go faster than that in a solid material
object
but that's kind of how that works
oh boy there's a question here from
julian a
who do i think the smartest person to
ever live
uh was or is or something
that's a weird question you know
smartness is not one of these things
that is on a a scale
of you know person a is smarter than
person b
is smarter than person c and so on you
know
if you try to assess how people will do
in different situations like
will this person be able to solve this
problem how long will it take them to do
it
depends on the problem depends on the
person depends
on you know whether they are in an
energetic mood
right then depends on lots of kinds of
things
it's it's not something that is and and
you know
there might be some i don't know take a
person like me there's some kinds of
problems i'm pretty good at solving
there's other kinds of problems that you
might think well
you know if this guy is at all smart he
should be able to solve this problem and
i'm not useless
solving these things um it's a
it's a thing where you know different
people different times different
knowledge but people have
they're able to solve different problems
now you know i think that
and sometimes by practicing a lot you
can get faster faster faster at solving
some particular kind of problem or
better better better at solving some
particular kind of problem like
like i spend a lot of my life trying to
solve fairly difficult problems
um i've learned over the years how to
solve difficult problems
if i were instead spending my time
solving a large number of very simple
problems
i would probably have a bunch of
different strategies and uh
i might be faster at solving the simple
problems if i'd done lots of those
um as opposed to being able to solve
some of the more difficult problems
because i've done lots of those
so i think it's a very uh it's something
where there isn't really a linear scale
now people
uh back in particular 1930s people were
very keen to have sort of a linear scale
of intelligence some kind of
intelligence quotient iq or something
where you could just
put people on a scale and say this
person is
iq smarter than this person so and that
was useful because
people were trying to figure out oh i
don't know for people joining the army
or something like that
you know who would get this kind of job
who would get that kind of job some
kinds of jobs
require more analytical skills less
analytical skills some kind of jobs
require you to be strong physically
stronger these kinds of things you know
can you rank people according to i mean
physical strength okay it's probably
fairly fairly easy at some level
you know how fast you can run something
like this you know
how accurately you can uh you know aim
something or whatever
and then there's well how fast can you
like figure stuff out
and what can you figure out so people
tried to invent these tests
for you know how how smart are you
um and they tried to make these kind of
puzzles
of you know what's the next thing in the
sequence that goes this to this to this
to this this
problem is pretty much any of those
things if you've done a lot of that
particular kind of thing
you're better at doing that particular
kind of thing
insofar as people have tests where
nobody has seen those tests before
then then that's slightly better but it
still just depends on what other things
you've done that are sort of related to
that i mean like for example
right now you know i'm watching the
somewhat horrifying story of
people trying to model this pandemic and
i'm watching so what happens when people
make these different kinds of models and
they get confused and they
can come to some conclusion and so on
you know i happen to have done a lot of
uh kind of computational mathematical
modeling in my life and so
certain kinds of things are like well
it's really pretty obvious that this is
true or that's true
but it won't be obvious to other people
but it's not i think because i'm any
smarter
it's just because i've done a lot more
of this kind of thing and so the
intuition that i have about how things
work
is better developed and it's faster for
me to to come to that conclusion or
another
but you know it's it became the case
that people
have tried for a long time to invent
tests that are kind of
neutral tests that are just tests of
something
intrinsic that one can call sort of
smartness
and uh back in the 1930s people came up
with this idea the
general intelligence quotient i think
they used to call it g
the coefficient of general intelligence
i don't know what on earth this means
i think it's quite meaningless actually
um the uh
uh and in fact you you find that um uh
and people
you know when people make standardized
tests like i don't know sats and things
like this
there's a question of what on earth are
they actually measuring
and you know really what matters in the
end is
what do you want to get out of the
answer to what are you measuring so for
example for the sat test for
for colleges in the us although many of
them are now dropping it probably a good
thing
but um uh it was you know
what does it really want to measure it
might want to measure something like
are people going to do okay in their
first year of college at this particular
college
if they get such and such a score in the
sat that's a reasonable question to ask
and you can say
well what's a way that you can probe the
answer to that question oh you ask these
kinds of
you you have this kind of quiz but it
isn't the case that if you do this kind
of quiz and you do better on it that
you're intrinsically more intelligent
it's just you fit this particular mold
that will cause you to have this effect
um
in this in this particular case so uh
you know it's a um i mean i've had the
good fortune to to know a lot of people
who um uh uh you know
the test for me is if i talk to them
about something and they kind of get
what i'm talking about
and they kind of jump ahead and they can
say what about this what about that it's
like oh that person's really smart in my
particular tiny little corner of the
things that i'm interested in
you know there are plenty of situations
there's always an interesting thing
you know i i have spent some of my life
doing basic science some of my life
doing things like running companies and
so on
um there's there's sort of very
different kinds of intelligence
where sometimes it'll be really obvious
to somebody
how this or that business situation will
will uh will work out and that person or
how
this or that situation with people will
work out and it's completely unobvious
if you ask that person
something about some sort of
mathematical kind of thing they won't
have any idea
but they'll have very good idea and be
able to be very smart
at figuring out something about how
people will behave in some situation or
some such other thing
so it's a very you know it's a very
multifaceted thing
and for me you know they're people who
seem smarter to me
just because they fit in better with the
way that i think about things and so on
and i think it's uh
it's probably i think it's that way sort
of intrinsically for everybody
um and i think it's it's hard to make a
sort of generalized
that there isn't really i don't really
believe in this notion of a generalized
uh
concept of that
okay a question here from saul do i
think it is possible to make
secret some big discovery related to
let's say ai
made by the government similar to the
way that the manhattan project was was
kept secret that's an interesting
question
i mean it's more a question about the
real world than it is a question about
some
about science but let me try and address
it so first thing a little bit of
history
so the manhattan project done in world
war ii was the project
to build the first nuclear weapons the
first atomic bombs
and the the knowledge of how to make an
atomic
bomb was and has been largely kept
secret
not it isn't really that secret it's
just that you need an awful lot of
pieces of technology
to build an atomic bomb and um uh
but but and so the fact that fortunately
there aren't more atomic bombs in the
world is more a consequence of the fact
that the sort of supply chain
for the kind of uranium and plutonium
whatever it is and
all the different pieces that those are
not
readily available it's also partly a
knowledge
it's a question of how you do all the
engineering to build all the things you
need to
produce the right explosions inside the
thing to compress things in the right
way et cetera et cetera
it's kind of complicated and you need a
lot of engineering backup
to be able to do it so that's one case
of um a place where where something has
been
both it's fairly secret how to how to
make it work but it's also more to the
point
the supply chain of all the pieces you
need and the engineering that you need
to be able to do
those are not readily available and and
that's really more the way that that can
be sort of held back
now another example is cryptography
making secret messages so that's a place
where
for it used to be true the people said
uh you've got to keep secret the way
you're making the secret messages
because as soon as people know how
you're making the secret messages
they'll be able to break the codes but
when you make it
a secret message there's both the method
of making it and there's the particular
password that you use to make that
particular message
and what was realized in the 1980s was
that it actually was
okay to tell people what method you used
to make the the secret message
you just had to not tell them the
password so it was a thing where
for a while people were saying oh my
gosh
you know we've got these methods for
making secret codes
and we don't want anybody else to know
about them because
otherwise they might be able to break
our codes now actually
the concern was not so much that the
concern was a different concern the
concern was
if they get these ways of making better
secret codes
then we won't be able to break the codes
that they're using
so you know country a says
we don't want to we've invented this way
of making secret codes
we don't want to give that way of making
secret codes
to country b because right now we're
listening to all those radio
transmissions made by country b
and we're able to decode those
transmissions
um because they're using inferior codes
that we know how to break
so there's a big issue in the 1980s
about whether whether
one should tell the world how
better secret codes work and that was
sort of decided
kind of by default by people just
publishing
out into the open literature the ways to
make these these very secret codes
and i'm i i think that that was a um i
mean that was i think it was sort of an
inevitable thing that that was going to
happen because unlike the nuclear
weapons case
where there's a giant complicated supply
chain once you know
the algorithm for making one of these
secret codes anybody can implement it on
any computer
so you know i think the real question of
what you can keep secret and what you
cannot
is partly a question of what is the
supply chain to the thing
look like like let's say you know let's
say you got this amazing ai
and had some method but in order to
train the ai
you had to use a trillion hours
of um even that's not possible we
couldn't get to that but you know
even um uh even a few million hours
of of cpu time of computer time to be
able to do the training
well in a sense even the method by which
the ai worked you could tell everybody
that
it's just they don't have the money to
spend millions of hours of computer time
to train the thing well now it gets a
little complicated because
usually there are some entities in the
world that would have the money to do
that large governments would have the
money to do that
but your average kind of private person
would not and so
you know i think that the i think the
reality of what can be kept secret
is partly what what do you need a
complex supply chain or something that's
expensive to produce
to be able to replicate and what's not
when it's just a fact
i think it's it's um uh you know you can
argue the
the uh whether it's good or bad to keep
it secret i think that's a complicated
question
i think it's very complicated question
that's sort of more of a question of
geopolitics
than it is a question of of um of
anything to do with science or
technology
um i mean certainly the the history of
things has generally been generally
the world does better when things aren't
secret i mean like a famous example
uh back in the um uh
what period of time in um
up until oh boy maybe the early days of
universities after 1200 a.d
but um before let's say 1800 a.d
um the in in
in great britain uh the following thing
was true in england
it was illegal to do human dissection it
was viewed as being
a sort of sacrilegious kind of thing to
to take
you know to dissect human bodies
um and that caused trouble for medical
research because if you don't know
how human bodies are built inside you
it's tough to know how they work and
that period of time in scotland it was
not illegal to do these things
and so a lot of development got done in
scotland of those things didn't happen
in england
and you know there are it's a very
complicated thing because there are
other things where people like like okay
let's be let's be very practical should
one be doing you know gain of function
mutation research
on viruses interesting question you know
should we be making viruses that are
more potent more powerful
than any that have existed in nature is
that a good idea or not should
the knowledge about how to do that how
widely should the knowledge about how to
do that be spread
well uh you know the truth is that cat
is already out of the bag
because uh like cryptography
genome sequences uh you know once you
have the sequence you have the story
um now it may be complicated to be able
if it's a if it's a complicated thing to
synthesize there may be some sort of
supply chain complexity there
but generally it's one of these things
where once you know that that's worth
doing
you can readily do it so i think that's
an interesting that's a that's another
interesting case
is you know if somebody discovers the
the absolutely
magic killer virus that would just kill
everything so to speak
what to do with that um you know the
fact is i think for both theoretical
and practical biology reasons it
probably no such virus exists
fortunately
but that would be a good interesting
case in point of uh
you know can one keep it secret is there
a sort of supply chain that's
complicated enough to do that
um i think that's a an interesting
question and i think that um
you know different governments around
the world have different attitudes
towards
the notion of secrecy and what the
obligations of people are to keep
secrets
if they know them and and all those
kinds of things um
and again it's more a story of
geopolitics and i don't think there's
any
i you know it's generally one of these
things where there's no right answer so
to speak
it's just like well i feel it should
work this way but somebody else may feel
it should work that way and kind of
you know the reason it's probably not a
bad thing that there are multiple
countries in the world is
different groups of people have
different general feelings about how
things should work and
so uh you know that's a good reason to
have different countries and so on
um okay that's enough enough geopolitics
here
um
let's see
uh all right a few
few other things here um
uh pomenities is asking uh any stories
about roger penrose
uh so i consider roger penner as a
friend and i was happy that he uh
won the nobel prize for physics a couple
of days ago now
um uh always a good thing i'm
a little amused by that because because
i view roger as being much more of a
mathematician than a physicist
um and uh i think sometimes he's
he's uh i remember back in 1977 when i
was a
student at oxford university um
i i didn't wasn't very good at going to
courses but i went to um
one one class that rajapanos gave about
about general relativity about the
mathematical theory of gravity
um and the thing that was always
charming about it was
he would do these giant derivations on
the blackboard and he would go from one
end of a big blackboard to the other end
a big blackboard
and at the end of it he would very
charmingly look up and look very very
puzzled
because he got the wrong answer and in a
sense that was probably a very
educational thing because i i used to
you know have a great time figuring out
what went wrong where and so on and uh
it's probably more educational than just
sort of seeing oh there's this
derivation of how this works
actually i just recently found my notes
from that class it's kind of interesting
the way that um
uh the things that i learned about
general relativity have have become
clarified at least to me
in this project about fundamental
physics that we've been doing recently
but um i would say that um uh
i think um i think roger's contributions
to mathematics have
been um uh and sort of the the uh
very mathematical end of physics have
been quite uh
uh have been have been wonderful i think
his
um uh his sort of thinking about um
sort of the physics of how brains work
and so on i'm less convinced by
i mean one of his most important results
uh hawking penrose singularity theorems
um that basically say under certain
circumstances it's inevitable
you will get a black hole when certain
when you have certain kinds of
of of sort of um uh when
when certain things are true about
matter in the universe
it is inevitable the black hole will
form and that means for example that the
the kind of giant giant garbage can at
the center of our galaxy the
100 000 solar mass black hole
at the center of our galaxy that's
gradually sort of uh
you know slowly accumulating lots of
stars from our galaxy
um there's sort of an inevitability of
the formation of that
that's implied by by roger's singularity
theorem
um but uh you know two other big
contributions
that rogers made one is a thing called
spin network so there's a thing called
twister theory
um both of them haven't really yet
been fully explored i think spin
networks
are somewhat like the models that we now
have of space-time
they're a way of thinking about space as
a discrete kind of thing but but his
particular way of thinking about space
is discrete
is much more elaborate than mine and i
it might eventually be equivalent but i
think it's i think it's overly elaborate
um the idea of twister theory um
but a little bit hard to explain here
but but um it's a it's a pretty
mathematical thing
but it's looking like some of the things
that we figured out about the sort of
fundamental structure of physics
need twister theory they kind of engage
with that that sort of direction in
mathematics which is really nice to see
um
let's see
um
okay people are asking to see my my
particle detector yeah i mean we should
do that at some point i i don't have it
on
the computer that i'm streaming from
right now um
the uh and i need to try it because it's
i was very excited because
somebody sent this to me um it's a
little uh
okay tell you a little bit of a story so
how do you detect particles you just got
this one particle it's going really fast
i told you one way using transport
radiation um
the main way that you detect a particle
is that
it uh well okay
the the most common way is that it
uh produces some kind of electrical
breakdown in something
so uh let's let's give an example of
this so for example when you have a
lightning strike
what's happened is that the there's this
giant voltage
between the cloud and the and the ground
and it would really like to be the case
that electricity that's at this very
high voltage would really like to be
conducted from the cloud down to the
ground
really like there'd be a wire from the
cloud to the ground but there isn't a
wire from the cloud to the ground
but that lightning strike is temporarily
making something like a wire
it's ionizing the air so that the
electrons in the air are stripped away
from their atoms
and the electrons just like electrons
can move in a wire in a in like a copper
wire or something
they can also move when they're stripped
away in a plasma
um they can they can move and that's
what's happening in a lightning strike
is that you're you're stripping the
electrons so that they can move freely
so that the electricity from the cloud
can be conducted down to the ground
okay so what happens is
that if you have a what's usually called
an ionizing particle
if you have a high energy particle that
might be from a cosmic ray might be from
something else
it it is doing
something a bit like that lightning
strike it's able to
um it in fact it could even be that
lightning strikes are initiated by the
presence
of you know where the lightning strike
happens could have something to do with
oh this cosmic ray happened to come
through in this place and so that kind
of created almost sort of a crack
that then this giant uh you know
um sort of uh this column of ionization
can can be produced in
okay so the way people detected
particles um
ionizing particles ah
yeah let's see boy um okay
roughly what happens is
you've got this particle maybe it's a
proton or something
and it's going to be uh it's it has
enough energy
that it's going to be doing like what
the lightning strike does and it's going
to be ripping electrons
out of their atoms um and
you can detect that happening by having
a little sort of microscopic
um lightning strike so the an early kind
of um
of particle detector with this thing
called the geiger counter
and if you've seen uh probably by now
i've got a geiger counter somewhere i
could show you guys someday
um the uh um you know geiger counters
and sort of the old time movies and
things you'll
you'll hear them it'll go you know click
click click click click
click and then when you're near a piece
of uh a source of radioactivity
a source of particles it will go click
really fast
and that's every one of those clicks is
like a microscopic lightning strike
that's being initiated by one particle
going
through this um uh this kind of
voltage difference and a gas um
this voltage difference in a gas and
sort of and that the presence of that
particle
causes it to break down to have this
little microscopic lightning strike
okay so that was an early method for
detecting particles
so years ago i
said to people who detected particles
you know these memory chips
that exist in computers they're very
sensitive to
uh you know to electric
to sort of being being perturbed
electrically
and you know in a typical um uh um
modern uh memory chip it's maybe
i don't know 10 000 electrons represent
one bit of information
and so if you kind of kick those and you
have an ionizing particle that goes near
there and it sort of
it produces it strips electrons out of
atoms and things like this
then you're going to every so often
you're going to change one of those bits
and um uh and that might be a way to
detect particles
they're like no no no never going to
work okay whatever
so many many years go by and in fact
the method of using things like memory
chips to detect particles has now become
quite standard
and and the idea is you know you've got
this memory chip it's got a billion bits
of memory in it
and the um and every so often if a
particle goes through
it's going to uh ionize some atoms and
it's going to produce some electricity
there
and that's going to show up as being a
bit got flipped
in the in the um uh in the memory chip
and you can you can set up memory chips
so that they are
uh usually you want them not to be
flipped so you want to sort of hold them
back from that but you can set them up
to be sort of closer to the edge so
they're more have a higher tendency to
be
to be flipped back in the day 1970s
1980s
used to be a problem that that
semiconductor memory
uh chip memory chips and so on uh used
to have a problem with cosmic rays
quite often and uh in um
um for example so the earth's atmosphere
shields us from most
most cosmic rays but the higher you go
you know as you go up like to denver for
example which is a mile high roughly
the amount of atmosphere above you is
less and so there's less shielding at
cosmic rays
so there are more cosmic rays more
radiation
in denver than there is on the surface
there's also more radiation near the
magnetic poles of the earth because of
the way particles spiral in through the
magnetic field
of the earth um more close to the poles
in any case so there are places where
there's more cosmic rays and it used to
be the case
that um computers would have more memory
errors in
um uh when you had them in these places
where you were higher up in the earth's
atmosphere with less
less shielding from cosmic rays and that
is a big problem in spacecraft
where you don't get much shielding at
all um and that's a big problem
that you can have uh problems from
cosmic rays and so on
more of a problem when you get out of
low earth orbit you go into deep space
you no longer have the
magnetosphere of the earth um which um
uh can protect uh that
can deflect some of those particles away
but um
the um in any case
that sort of got solved because
uh memories memory chips on on at least
server type computers
tend to have error correction which
means even if one little bit is flipped
there's an algorithm that can can say no
you know we can tell that one bit got
flipped
that bit is wrong let's correct it in
this way
that kind of error correction doesn't
exist on things like phones the memory
and phones doesn't tend to have that
um and um uh so in fact people have
tried this project
recently to make a giant global cosmic
ray detector
by having people just essentially well
they're not just using memory chips
they're also using the cameras of phones
which have
which use the same kind of electronic
mechanisms um
and they're saying you know just cover
your camera no light gets the camera
but just if there is a if one of these
charged particles goes through the
camera
it will essentially register a pixel um
and uh you know see if you can detect
cosmic rays that way and see
maybe you can detect sort of giant
cosmic ray showers
uh spread across lots of a large large
area on the earth
by doing that it's kind of a fun thing
to try to do i'm not sure it's yet been
very successful
um but why was i digressing on this we
were talking about um
oh yes so so anyway um this idea of
using kind of memory chips
um or things like like
the way solid state cameras work um
to detect particles is something that's
become pretty common
and there's now a little detector that
somebody sent me that you can connect to
a computer
that actually can show you the track of
a particle going through and so i really
i haven't seen one of these yet i
haven't really hooked it up properly um
i i really want to see a muon track
because i've never really seen a muon
um and i want to i want to do that
um
let's see
yeah as people are asking for me to show
various kinds of objects i have it'll be
a fun thing to do
um all right one last
last question here from krasner
do i believe that there was an idea of
technology before modern civilizations
uh so that's one of the questions there
is is there technology that was
understood
but has been lost uh quite possibly yes
i mean we know one really good example
of that
which is mechanical computers so
there is this thing that um
uh people used to think oh
even mechanical computers even computers
that have cogs and things in them
were not invented until the 1600s that's
what people thought until very recently
and then it was discovered somebody
found well it's a sort of funny story
there was an island called um
antikythera
in the that's a greek island and there
were some sponge divers
off the coast of antikythera around 1900
who found this shipwreck
and they found all kinds of cool things
in the shipwreck all kinds of statues
all kinds of other stuff and they
brought all the stuff and it wound up in
the athens museum
and one of the things they found was
this kind of lump of stuff a
kind of a lump that was you know kind of
a
sort of corroded metal lump okay all
so it goes okay sometime i think in the
1950s
somebody by mistake dropped this metal
lump
on the floor it broke in two and
at the exposed surface there were some
cogs
so that's a really bizarre thing because
people didn't really know that things
with cogs had existed
like that precision things with cogs
that existed well for a long time people
didn't really know what this thing was
eventually um it became possible to do
ct scans
so that you could uh sort of see inside
without taking the thing apart
and then actually a friend of mine uh
funded the project to really try and
decode
how the thing worked and basically what
what's happens it's not known exactly
when it's from it's either the around
the first century bc to the first
century a.d
it's a thing which is a mechanical
calculator it's got many many cogs
and it computes the position of the sun
and the moon and the earth
and it has a sort of elementary way of
computing the position of the times of
eclipses
it has all kinds of stuff in it and it
also has
kind of a clue it has a it has marked
off in time
the time of some version of the olympic
games back from those days and so that
gives kind of a clue about where it came
from
it probably came from the island of
sicily particularly the the
the city of syracuse um in sicily
um and uh that was where a chap called
archimedes who was a
well-known mathematician of of antiquity
lived
and it's always been kind of my um uh
my little sort of concept that um
you know that archimedes um as well as
uh you know coming up with all kinds of
modern things that we know in
mathematics today
also had a business kind of making you
know mechanical computers on the side
it's kind of a
it's kind of funny for somebody like me
because i've spent my life making
tools that are software tools now that
allow one to do things like mathematical
computation and it's kind of nice to
imagine that maybe archimedes was kind
of in the same business that i'm in
um but in any case the the um uh that
was a case where nobody had had any idea
that there were mechanical computers in
antiquity they thought they originated
in the 1600s
but by chance discovery there's only one
of it there's only one example
um we know that these these things
existed then
we don't know how many things like the
anticathera device existed
now you know there were some clues like
cicero ancient
roman orator writer
you know he mentioned that he had seen
some kind of calculational device
but nobody took that seriously they
didn't know what it meant
so it's like we don't know what that is
so so um
uh you know nobody really paid much
attention to that for for 2000 years
um so i think that um uh
the so that's an example of where
something uh technology for antiquity
sort of showed up again and there's some
other ones which are a little bit
mysterious to do with
materials like various metals and so on
that existed in antiquity i mean there's
some really weird things like
like there's some metals that like
couldn't have existed at that time in
antiquity because people didn't know how
to make them
but actually they were probably came
from meteorites which were obviously
rare but you could find them and then
they had metal in them which was
of a kind that couldn't be made by the
by the technological processes of that
time
but you know there's a question of what
what other technology from ancient times
could have been lost
today um you know there's possibility of
various kinds of medical things
i mean there's you know a lot of drugs
that we have today i mean there aren't
that many known drugs there's maybe less
than 2
000 sort of known you know approved
drugs and many of them are quite a lot
of them are derived from
natural things so to speak you know from
some particular bark of some particular
tree has some particular molecule in it
that turns out to be useful for some
particular purpose and so on
and uh it's quite possible that
you know in antiquity there were other
things known that oh by the way
you know if somebody develops purple
spots of this kind
you use the bark of the such and such
tree in it and it fixes it
um and you know exactly how that works
and
what diseases people might have had then
versus now it'll be different
and you know there was no fda to approve
things and maybe some of it was complete
nonsense but that's an example something
that quite quite possibly could have
existed
you know could there have been uh could
there be another technology that we
don't know about today
uh an interesting question i mean the
antikythera device is definitely a
wake-up call about that
because it's like there's lots of kinds
of things so so for example
anything made of wood it's going to be
gone we don't know what it is the very
first mechanical calculator
uh probably was made by a guy called
chicag who was a
friend of kepler's um and
the thing he made was made of wood and
so that
hasn't survived the metal the first
metal calculators like the one made by
pascal
in 1640s um has survived
because it was made of metal and you
know it doesn't sort of uh
just sort of decay away um so you know
it's hard to know what could have
existed in in those um
uh at that time and and you know is it
uh
quite a lot of technology we have today
sort of builds on top of
well there's two kinds of building one
is conceptual building
the other is just manufacturing of
devices
so you know i don't think that there was
a
uh you know a webcam that existed in
antiquity because to get to a webcam
you have to have an awful lot of stuff
that has to exist in the kind of supply
chain
of um uh the um
um uh
uh the the you know the you have to have
that supply chain to be able to um
to produce that kind of material it's an
interesting question what other
technology might have existed
that we don't know today um i don't know
i mean there's certainly
there are uh who knows maybe there are
throwing sticks like boomerang-like
things
that somebody had figured out this
really clever way of of shaping it so
that
it would do some really clever thing um
that uh
um that we don't um that we don't know
about today because it was made of wood
and it's just been lost um
i think uh um
a comment from merrick here there were
papers found from alexander that
detailed steam engines
uh yeah yeah so that's another
interesting point so hero of alexandria
for example
uh was famous for having sort of
invented a variety of kinds of of
of of things yes it is it is one of the
issues
that things sometimes get involved
invented for toys
and nobody knows what the point is so
there were many kind of automata toys
that are like little robots
that do things and it's like okay that's
cool you know that existed in 1500
1600 a.d and um it's like that's cool
but what do we do with it
oh you make an industrial robot out of
it what's an industrial robot we haven't
thought of industrial robots
so yes there are there are things that
are that are viewed as being sort of
toys and novelties that end up being
things that are important later because
people get the the sort of you know
there's the advance of the concepts and
the advance of the supply chain of the
technology
and you know it can often be the case
that there are things where people say i
mean
people had known about oh i don't know
uh
well magnets they kind of figured out i
think they knew about magnets
i think a solid thousand years before
people started using them
i'm not sure about this about i'm not
sure when compasses were invented that's
a good question
but certainly i don't know things like
liquid crystals
the substances that make liquid crystals
were known for a long time but the idea
of using them
to make displays that was a very recent
idea
so yes there are plenty of things i mean
another famous example here's an example
so uh you know carbon comes in several
forms
it comes in graphite you have in pencils
it comes in diamond
all of those are just carbon atoms
they're just arranged in different in
different patterns
people thought okay there are two forms
of carbon great all done
well it turns out that in in common soot
there's actually another form of carbon
called usually called uh buckminster
fullerene
after buckminster fuller who who
described not
about carbon but described this kind of
shape that's kind of the
the pattern of of seams on a soccer ball
you can make that into kind of a network
and you can imagine putting carbon atoms
at those at the sort of positions in the
in the um uh uh soccer balls
and i think that the um um
the thing that um uh was realized is
actually common soot has if you analyze
it correctly has
tons of these buckyballs and these
buckyballs
well uh that turned into things like
graphene and other kinds of of
nanomaterials
which one is slowly managing to realize
have all kinds of uses
um and uh but but yes it's a it's often
a challenge once something is known in
the world
to know how it will be used steve is
pointing out that there were vacuum
tubes for
a hundred years before anyak is that
right i don't
think quite that long vacuum tubes the
thermionic effect
was around 1910 i think so i think that
i'm i'm guessing there were only vacuum
tubes for
um for 35 years before the first
computer is made of vacuum tubes
i think because the first radios with
vacuum tubes
were am i right
in the 1920s there were certainly radios
with vacuum tubes
um and uh for those who don't know what
vacuum tubes are
in in um oh gosh
another time maybe another time that the
the technology that predated the
transistors
that are made for all of our current
technology and instead of
transistors which are these microscopic
things made out
of solid pieces of semiconductor vacuum
tubes were these glass
things that had actual glowing filaments
inside them when i was a kid for example
um it was still the case that um uh
transistors were rare
and vacuum tubes were pretty common in
um in
in devices um
here's another uh comment from america
about batteries i
i don't know about batteries i i'm i'm a
little suspicious about batteries
because
developing the electrochemistry of a you
know to develop
a a a a potential in a va an electric
potential in a battery
is not so hard and can happen even
quotes naturally
does happen naturally it happens in our
nerve cells and things like this
so knowing i mean that's another
complete kind of worms
in understanding ancient technology is
you find
something and you say what was it for
you know you find the stonehenge
arrangement of stones
what was it for was it some amazing
piece of technology like i just saw a
couple of days ago
somebody who says they've discovered
that there was uh amazing acoustics
amazing sound properties of stonehenge
it's like really
well was that intentional was that part
of the design of stonehenge
or is that purely coincidental um and
it's uh you know people often wonder
oh they found you know this arrangement
of stones left
in um this is a thing where i live in
new england
it's a it's a common issue people will
find uh
um the um uh you know things that were
arrangement of stones
was this an arrangement of stones put
there by native americans you know 500
years ago
on purpose or is this just a random
collection of stones
if it's on purpose what was the purpose
describe what was actually going on
so it's often kind of hard to you know
when you find an object
knowing what it was for is non-trivial
and maybe that purpose
doesn't exist anymore i mean people i i
remember it's a story i've i've um
i've kind of told um uh a few times i
i was notable incident for me of
visiting some archaeological site in
peru
where uh you know there are all these
stones and they're all arranged
in different ways and all kinds of
things and you ask kind of
what was that for and the person who was
showing us around was like
you know that was for ceremonial
purposes which is a
translates into um uh
you know we have no idea we have no
modern context for what this was for
you know it was for some you know
ancient quotes ritual well maybe the
ancient ritual i mean
maybe you know um
sitting here and waving and looking at a
at a um
camera lens might be a modern ritual of
some kind you know what is it for so to
speak um you know it's it's a um
uh it's one of these things where where
what is somebody's very purposeful
activity it's another person's ritual
because they don't understand what it's
for
um and i think that that's uh that's
sort of an issue in trying to understand
ancient technologies you find a thing
and you ask what was this for and it may
not be
if we don't have a modern context we
don't have a similar thing that's
happening today
it may be um uh um it may be the
the um um uh you know we may not be able
to to connect those things
all right i have to wrap up because i
have to go do something else
um but anyway great to chat with you
guys and thank you for all these
interesting questions and comments
and i look forward to seeing you
next week all right i gotta go
bye for now